this is actually a song that I had
written on the way to making a motion
and even with the b-sides I almost snuck
it on there we also have passion if it
just felt a little theatrical a little
over-the-top so perfectly for a
ballerina sort of cartoon animated
musical yeah Carly rains new song maybe
on the soundtrack for the animated film
leap but the video is directed by
Francis Ford Coppola granddaughter Gia
Coppola
[Music]
I love the collaborative process when
you have written a song and somebody
else puts their own genius spin on the
storyline of it so she sort of pitched
it to me as like behind the scenes been
making of the video of the rehearsal
thing and it sounds like Carly Rae has a
lot going on behind the scenes of her
own life the 31 year old was just
announced as the opening act of the 2018
leg of Katy Perry's witnessed tour and
she started work on her fourth studio
album it's just at a place where I'm
really open to not really having to
define what I'm making in so this summer
I probably 16 housing I'm trying not
just overwrite to overwrite I think over
writing comes from a place of just
really being curious about where to
experiment and being attracted to
different sounds and sometimes that just
makes like do these install but you have
to like get them out of your system on